in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Alex
and Stephanie drop by hey guys how are
you thank you welcome welcome how can we
help today
[Music]
sorry that's ok we we are currently
debt-free except for our mortgage good
and we are looking for you want to know
how to prepare for Stephanie to lower
her work and then come so that we can
and she can stay for the second baby the
second baby she got a baby and you won't
go home be full-time mom part-time mom
basically I am a nurse so I work three
12-hour shifts I want to take it down to
two once we have a second baby okay cool
so well it's a fairly simple thing what
would your income drop by and start
living on that now
okay so calculate what your income will
become if you do that and start living
on that and you'll know you're living on
that if you put the rest of it in the
bank or towards your dad or something
right so you know whatever then whatever
the numbers let's say it drops by eight
thousand dollars a year whatever it is
$10,000 or $20,000 a year whatever it
drops by okay then you need to live on
what your new income would be if you did
that there and you know you're doing
that if you're banking the difference so
you need to live on you at two days a
week instead of you at three days a week
and one day needs to go in the bank does
that make sense yes so that proves to
yourself that you're really doing it
because otherwise you're kind of like
well I think we can do it maybe and we'd
like to do it and then you don't and
then you end up going you know putting
that extra day I'm weak on a credit card
and run yourself back up into debt or
something and so just because you didn't
plan it out you have to learn to live on
the new income so go ahead and practice
that now and you know you're doing it by
banking the difference is that logical
yes very cool
well congratulations is baby - on the
way no not yet okay so you just kind of
think it through how to do this just
planning yeah well that'd be a great way
to do it what baby step are you on are
you out of debt yes we're in four or
five and six okay so that's easy then
yeah
just gonna pile up some extra money for
the fun of it right now not to get ready
the extra money's not to feed the money
that you're short now we're not gonna
subsidize that because that money will
burn up but it's it's in order to
practice living on a lower income than
you have been is that is that logical
yes absolutely
you got this congratulations thanks for
stopping by guys thanks